Given some sample data
how do we populate a ListView?
Let's look at an example
of some contact data
and how it can be displayed in the list.
We start with our raw data
of contacts which is three contacts,
as well as our profile images.
Then we pass this data into the adapter
so it has a reference to it.
The adapter also knows
how to build a list item layout
for each of these data items.
So it could go ahead
and create the layouts for them.
But we don't need to create the views yet
until the ListView requests
that it needs them.
For example, if you had hundreds
of contacts here,
you wouldn't want hundreds of layouts
sitting around that aren't being used.
Then when you bind
the adapter to the ListView,
the ListView will ask how many items
are actually in the data set.
And the adapter will check
in the data set, there's three items,
so we will return that to the ListView.
Now the ListView knows that it will
have to populate itself
with three list items.
Now the ListView starts at position zero
and asks for the list item layout
located at that position.
It goes back to the adapter
and the adapter checks
that at position zero,
we have the contact, Anna.
The adapter knows how to create
a list item layout from the contact, Anna.
So, it goes ahead and does that.
And then we return it to the ListView.
And now we see that the 'Anna' list item
is located at the zeroth position in the list.
Next the ListView wants to get
the item at position 1,
so ask for the layout from the adapter.
The adapter checks that at position 1,
we have the contact, Bob.
The adapter knows how to create
a list item layout for Bob,
so it goes ahead and does that
and then it returns it to the ListView.
And now we see that the list item for Bob
has been successfully added
to the ListView at position 1.
Now the ListView fetches
its last item because it knows
that there was three list items to expect.
It fetches the last list item layout
at position 2 by asking the adapter.
The adapter checks that at position 2,
we have Charlie, as well as that image.
And we know how to make
a list item layout for Charlie,
so we can go ahead and do that,
and return it to the ListView.
And now we have the list item for Charlie
at position 2 in the list.
And we have our complete list.